guys are here to talk about grassroots
today were latest film which is a
political comedy about local elections a
race for them terminus about yeah we
were here to talk about the new american
pie reunion well let's talk about that
this political comedy would you do yes
well it's actually based on a true story
isn't it i've wondered therefore what
stage did you actually get to meet the
real life guys that you're bringing to
the big screen both of you you had
different stages clearly for the fred
that week he's got his answer I mind
mine is I met Phil after we had already
commenced filming so so we were a couple
of weeks in and and I met Phil he came
to set and I I'll never forget it was
this wonderful compliment he gave me
it's really a compliment to Stephen but
he told me he said you know I was
watching you do what you're seeing and I
feel like you really have me down like
you really like I really like believe it
like I and what was striking about that
what was amazing about that is is that I
wasn't trying to do him you know and
Stephen was adamant from the beginning
that that we weren't trying to you know
do an impression we're in trying to you
know that that that the real phil
campbell and and his book that he wrote
and the stories and there were sort of a
template that we were going to build
upon and we were going to create our own
characters and but i think that's just
it's it's a reflection of you know
Stephen new Phil and Stephen knew what
he wanted to get from the story and from
the character and he directed me in a
way that when phil campbell came to said
he was like I totally get it I thought
that was interesting so I imagine you
had a little bit more history a little
bit different I mean first of all just
phil was kid his 20s did this campaign
sort of for all the reasons the movie
talks about which is not all the right
reasons you've been fired and he just
was angry i thought what the hell I'll
throw this crazy guy up in the faces of
the Seattle politicians who I don't like
you know so he comes into it for all the
wrong reasons he did in his twenties
he wrote this book he's a journalist so
he wrote this book the book had a small
life didn't didn't really didn't do that
well find it was called Zion check for
president I would have run away told him
change the title but so so he didn't
ever expect anything to happen and a
friend of mine at nation books which is
where I discovered the book so just with
a long of the seven or eight other books
gave me that book to read and that was
the book that fascinated me i think he
just thought it would be the seven
copies that were sold one of which was
on his shelf would be the end of it and
that was sort of it so all of a sudden
what I talked to him and said I could
turn into a movie I mean I've made a
bunch of movies I hadn't made a feature
film at that point for a few years but I
had made a bunch of both he's been doing
LED TV I don't think he really believed
anything was ever going to come of it
but there was some glimmer of he's done
this before it might happen again but I
don't believe it and I don't think I
mean imagine you or you know one of your
friends because you're in the media but
someone who has never been involved with
Hollywood or movie making someone comes
to use it's a little book you wrote we
want to turn into a movie so it was it
was fun working with him because I knew
right away I'm going to turn this into a
movie and it took a while we work on the
script and I'd love having people
involved with the process and pulling
them into this weird journey of
moviemaking and all of it which is
pretty gritty a lot of the time so he I
had him work on the script at one point
he wanted to rewrite the script because
everyone thinks they can also write
scripts and um and i did pull one or two
things out of the script including the
scene at don't know the scene that he
saw you know but but he did so i was
working on capturing his inflection who
he was what he was like he's a very so
obsessed obsessed kind of guy yeah but
then I got to follow him all the way
along and then met grant right before we
started shooting and I'd talk with him
on the phone and emailed back and forth
I was a little worried because he's kind
of a wild character and grab turned out
to be just spectacular but they're two
very different people I can grants in
Mexico City and with a bookstore now I
mean very different bills in New York is
interesting you're talking about how
how for reasons sort of reasons my fall
came Jason's character came on board and
to do this campaign it's interesting in
a way that you kind of got dragged in by
his friend didn't he to do it it's at a
time when obviously he lost his job and
stuff and wins if you I'd of you'd ever
been in that situation before where a
kind of friend has dragged you into a
situation you've kind of been carried
along by it hmm well Stephen drag me
that's the only thing I can think of um
oh boy I mean there's there's there's a
few regrettable late nights in vegas
that i can think of a couple of poor
decisions come on just one more stop but
you know things like this i I you know I
I I don't know I mean I I haven't you
know group phil was at a real and end
grant at a real sort of crossroads you
know and i think you know i have
certainly been at crossroads i think in
a way i'm at one now but I've been I
haven't had that kind of I think
relationship where I've been sort of
reluctantly pulled in only to find
myself enlightened which is what
happened with Phil you know what timing
is everything huh really you know it's
interesting because I think when you
look at his character carefully the most
critical thing that's happened it
happens to him as he's fired this is a
really committed journalist and Phil is
a very committed journalist and he was
working for the stranger which the
people in Seattle know is a kind of it's
actually become a much better paper or a
much much better known paper in Seattle
than it was at the time so he kind of
felt like he was at the bottom of the
barrel and then they could fired from
that was devastating and I think one of
the things the movies also exploring is
that a lot of people get fired nowadays
you know a lot of people are out of work
lobular unemployed and that
psychological effect which we played
within a relatively humorous way but
generally doesn't feel humors when it's
happened I was fired once off
and it was devastated devastating and I
think the reaction of Phil's of your
character is less about being pulled
into it by by grant which I think
there's an element of but more about
revenge more about wanting to just it
could be was going to get work it was
going to that it was a way of sort of
saying screw you which is not the way
it's described those two words or not
the words that are used in the movie but
those are the words that I would use now
and sort of dives into it for almost you
know malevolent reasons what I'm
fascinated by is that journey of going
from cynicism and hopelessness to being
hopeful and understanding that you
really can make a difference I think
it's one of the things that people
really emerged from in the movie is that
and we've showed it to all students and
a lot of young people the idea that you
don't think you have a voice well you
don't have a voice unless you start to
speak and for whatever reason you start
to speak you discover that you have a
voice and any single person can make a
profound difference it's not easy you
know and these characters grow up and
it's funny allow the ways but ultimately
it's about growing up and going have a
voice and I'm going to use it and the
great relationship you have with joel
david moore as well that could you know
on screen that it was off screen as well
with that onset prank he had tell me a
little bit yeah Joel Joel and I Joe and
I had a great time that there's one
prank in particular that I just took on
this life he would like he he he set
traps for me oh he's like I trapped you
so this would range from any it would be
like when I would he was like true he
would like rig these traps when I like
opened a door or something so he'd be
like you called me like at the hoodie be
at the hotel it'd be like hey man come
up to my room for a drink before we go
to dinner fig okay and I go up and he's
like I left a door unlocked you don't
like okay and I opened the door and
literally his the whole couch from his
room is like leaning against the door
but then like on top of the couch is
like the desk chair on top of the desk
chair is like shampoos filming all
shampoo bottles like
rant like he arranged in size but and I
opened the door and everything just kind
of falls on but not even that well just
kind of like it falls off to the side
and he films it and we just died and
laughter but then we just kept up with
it and so it would be like he would do
it at the trailer like and you know he'd
be like he'd be filming me be like what
are you doing jeez I'm like along the
trailer man I'm gonna get to take it a
little nap and you'd be like okay and I
got open the door and a cushion would
come down on me I mean but it would
range inside sometimes it just be like
one like you know a coke can would fall
bear or something anyway he would set
traps for me this was a running thing
and that's by the way you can go to
grassroots to film calm I think that's
what it's here isn't it it's it's a
threesome like oh yeah you can see all
these practically we have hundreds of
videos I think it's one of the things
that also i love more and more about the
world of media which is just the whole
internet web with a YouTube world which
we use console because again it's very
grassroots just all these pranks and
also Cedric the Entertainer there's a
malaria stay of him that are on the
website so you can see those that yeah
you